- Oh my gosh. dude
A seven pound piece of pizza
that's nothing to me.
Are you Kidding me?
Oh my God.
Alright guys so it's my
lunch break at Buzzfeed
right now and I just found
a seven pound pizza burrito
in New York.
And I'm making a video out of it
so I can get it for free
and Buzzfeed can pay for it.
Seven pounds I don't think
I even weight seven pounds.
The only problem is
the place is an hour away so I need a car.
- So why are you bringing me on this.
- 'Cause you're the food guy
you ate like the biggest slice of pizza.
You ate the spiciest curry.
You ate pizza ice cream and
and you have a car so.
- Alright so this is a
seven pound pizza burrito
and we are splitting one?
We are doing one each?
- One each.
- Do you honestly think that you're gonna
be able to finish this?
- Easy.
- There's no way.
You weigh what?
Like 150 pounds?
- Yeah.
- Okay so I weight nearly
75 pounds more than you do.
So a seven pound piece of
pizza that's nothing to me.
That's like a huge portion
of your body weight.
- You weigh so much more than me that
you're probably way more
conscious about your weight
so a seven pound pizza is
like way more stressful
for you than it is for me.
- Right there.
Russo Russo.
(upbeat Italian music)
- Everybody I pray that
I see somebody finish it.
That would make me so happy
to know that it can be done.
- It's huge you need like six people.
- Yeah, it's bigger than you.
- There's a lot, there's a lot in there.
- I'm still feeling confident,
I still feel confident.
- Every time I roll it,
it still makes me nervous.
It's gonna fall apart and all my hopes
and dreams are gonna shatter.
- Oh my gosh oh oh my gosh dude.
- This is big.
- I just want you to see how big this is
okay so you can see compared to my body.
It's bigger than me isn't it.
Going for it.
Oh yes.
- I think you very often
forget when you see a challenge
like this that it's gonna taste good.
- Tomorrow I'm gonna wake up
I'm gonna have acne all over my face.
Aren't you lactose intolerant?
- I am lactose intolerant.
- Gonna be a poopy party over here.
I feel like a lot of
people are gonna be like
oh it's a pizza do you
think it's a burrito?
- I mean it's definitely
a rolled up pizza but in the same way that
a burrito is just a rolled up tortilla.
I don't know commenters is this a burrito?
- [Man] How you guys doing over there?
- Terrible.
- This is great.
- You think this is an easy challenge,
you see all this pizza.
Why does it look like I have
so much more than you?
- 'Cause I've eaten so
much more than you do.
- You think you'll finish it?
- Yeah.
- You don't feel sick?
- You're really close.
Are you kidding me?
Oh my God no way,
no way he's gonna do it,
oh my God oh my God.
Did not no he's not done.
- [Man] Did you just eat it?
- I've never known a
piece of pizza to beat me
but this is ah I've met my match here.
I'm not happy with how
this played out here today.
(slow sad music)
I forgot to pay.
(upbeat music)
Two blizzards,
do you want a blizzard?
- Yeah I want a blizzard.
- There's always room
for ice cream.
- Are we gonna have to blur
at the name dairy queen?
- No it's not sponsored.
- We're not sponsored.
- Hey Unsolved is on a new channel
And now your part.
- [Men] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.